from where we stopped
so now uh
so now uh we will start
i will start talking about guardian
flows in a very informal way you will
see much more on gradient flows in uh
kathy craig's lecture tomorrow but let
me give just an informal introduction
now
so
to grab them close
in space
so
let me now assume h
to be
so h
uber space
so if you want you can still think
h equal to rd in general
so
let
let v
be a function
from h to r c one
and now given
a point x zero in h
we want to define the gradient flow
starting at x zero so the gradient flow
fee starting at zero
so
the gradient flow
indicated by gf
from now
starting from x0
is given by
the following ode
that is
x at time 0 equal to x0 that is the
starting point
and then the time derivative
of x is equal to minus the gradient of v
at x of t
so let me illustrate this with a
with a simple picture so suppose
this is our fee
so in this case it's also come back spot
yeah it's not necessarily convex so this
is our point at zero and then the
gradient flow
follows the direction
of minus gradient of v
and
so this is now an audi system
and
let me do an observation so note
that
if
x of t is a solution
of
gf
it holds that
it does the following so we do the
the time derivative
of v
along x of t and we see that this is
simply gradient of v
of x of t square product x dot of t
and this is by definition of gradient
flow
minus the gradient of v square
this is positive so this is negative
and what is telling us this very simple
computation this telling us that a
the function fee
decreases
along the curves
x of t and this is very important and
also tell us
that
d over dt of v of x of t so the time
derivative of f of x of t is equal to
zero if and only if x of t is a critical
point of v so even the leaf
modulus of graphene at x of t
is equal to zero
so in particular
so if phi
as a unique stationary poi and as a
unique
stationary point
so think
to the case
free convex
so in this picture
this is our
our
stationary point that is also a global
minimizer in this case
then we expect
that as time goes to zero
x of t converges to this global
minimizer x bar
okay
now we want to give a meaning
to this expression where we see that we
are comparing
x dot of t to the gradient of a certain
function
in an even space so
let me
change page here it is
so as a general fact
a given fee from h to r
we can define the differential of v at x
it is a function for from h to r
s
so the differential of v
attacks in the direction v
is defined as the limit as epsilon goes
to zero
of p of x plus epsilon b
minus v of x over
epsilon
and this what is telling us this is
telling us that if is regular enough
then the map
the fee
of x
belong to the dual space
h star you have seen already this all
these notations in um
in uh ashley wilson
uh she wilson
talk in on the first day
so um
okay so the differential is in the dual
space and on the other hand
um so on the other hand
if t
x of t
is a curve
in
values in h
then x dot of t is just a limit
as epsilon goes to zero of x
t plus epsilon
minus x of t
over epsilon and this belongs to h so we
are comparing something
that um
is in in the dual of age and something
that is uh in age so we need
so to then to define a gradient flow we
need to identify h and h star and this
can be done if we introduce a scalar
product so
if
we indicate by the brackets
a scalar product
on h times h
then
we can define
the gradient
of fiat x
as the unique element as the unique
element
of h such that
the scalar product between
gradient phi of x
and guess p
is exactly the differential of x in the
direction b
followed b
in h
okay in other words the square product
allows us to identify the gradient and
the differential and that and thanks to
this identification we can now make
sense of
x dot of t equal minus gradient of v
of x of t
so this will make sense for now now
so to define the gradient flow
of v we need a square product and then
the gradient flow depends on the scalar
product so um
to define
a gradient flow
so we didn't find the gradient flow
of v
we need
a scalar product
and then
the running flow depends
on the choice of this color product
okay we will see it soon
so i will not enter in the question
about how to construct solution to this
problem because you will see this in uh
in the in the lecture by katie craig but
also you have seen it in a way with an
approach via implicit euler in
in the in the crash course by asha
wilson so
i will now focus on some features of
this gradient flows besides the fact of
finding a solution so remark
uniqueness and stability
so let's see
b convex
and x of t
y of t
solutions
of gradient flow starting
from
x 0 and y 0 respectively
v
c 1
just to the manipulations
so
if we do if we do
the time derivative of the norm of the
difference of these solutions at time t
so the norm of x of t minus y of t
square
this is the scalar product between
x of t minus y of t against
x dot of t minus
y dot of t
and by definition of gradient flow since
they are both solution this is minus
x of t minus y of t
sorry
it's a comma
and graph of v of
x of t
minus graph v
of y of t
and this is
smaller than zero
where this this inequality
comes from the facts so comes
from
the
convexity
of fin
so also this time derivative is is
smaller than zero and what is telling us
is telling us that the gradient flow is
unique and stable so by stable i mean
that effect zero and white zero are
close then x time x t and y t remain
uniformly closed for all times and this
is a very important
very important feature of reading flows
and now to go on i need another
definition that is the definition of sub
differential that you we have also seen
some of you may also have seen in um
asha wilson talk but just let me mention
it again for for having a self-contained
lecture
so the notion of subdifferential
um
generalize the notion of derivative of
um to convex functions that are not
necessarily differentiable thing for
example to the function modulus of x
so let me now go
to give a definition of subdifferential
so
so given v
from rd
to r
convex
we can define the subdifferential of v
at x
so
the subdifferential of v at x can be
defined
as the set of all y in our d
such that for all that
we have the following
we have that ph obset is larger than phi
of x plus
y
z minus x
and
the subdifferential of c
is the union
on all x in rd
of the product
x
times
the v of x
okay and this is contained in rd times
rb
now let me just draw a picture because
this definition will be even more clear
with with a picture
so what does it mean to be a
subdifferential of x suppose that you
have a convex function
that
that has a corner so this is this with a
bit of
imagination from your side is a convex
function v
and this in this point
the function is not differentiable it is
a corner
so um
then you can draw
all the lines that are passing through
x0 so
with our tangent
and so
all these lines um so the the slope of
all these lines um
are in the sub differential in the
faster in the subdifferential
so
of course this is a generalization of
the differentiability so
[Music]
if v
is differentiable at x dot
actually x bar
then
the subdifferentiable the
subdifferential
of phi at x bar is equal to the gradient
of v at x bar
so
just for example if you have
the function modulus of x this is zero
and
so these are differentiable they have
differential at the origin is the set
so the subdifferential
of
modulus of x at the point zero
is the interval minus one
one um but this was already shown before
so
let me now
um
pass to an important example
that is um
how to to let's say to
to see the heat equation as l2 gradient
flow of the dirichlet energy so example
sl2 gradient flow
of the diesel energy
so uh now for this example we have h
that is
l2
over t so note that we are in infinite
dimension and our function is
field u
it is defined as follow
is defined like as one half integral
over rd
of grad u
square in the x
if u is in w12
of
rd
and plus infinity otherwise
so the claim
we call this so few view is the
dirichlet energy
so the claim
is that
the subdifferential
of fee at u is not empty
if and only if
laplacian of u
is in l2
and in that case
the subdifferential
of v at u is equal to
minus laplacian audio
so
to to to formally
show a bit how to how to see how to see
this thing let me just
show briefly an implication
the other is is very similar
so i wanted to to let
you still see the directional energy
so assume
that lam that the platinum view is in l2
so now we use the definition of phi
so
um
for any
w
we have
that phi
of u plus w
minus v of u is equal to the integral
over rd
to grad u square product graph
w
dx
plus one half integral
of modulus of graph w square
and this this latter
quantity is always positive
so
this is also greater equal of the
integral over rd
of grad u square product
w
and then integrating by part
this is equal to minus laplacian of u
w
dx
and now if you recall the definition of
subdifferential you have field view plus
w minus v of u larger of equal
of this
this quantity and being in the
subdifferential would mean phi of u plus
w
minus v of u
larger of equal of the scalar product in
l2 between
v and w
so let's say
minus laplacian of u plays the role
of the v in the different definition of
the sub differential so you can see that
we proved our implication so this means
that minus laplacian of u belongs to the
subdifferential of v
at q
so when we add that we can say that the
gradient flow with respect to delta
scholars product
is data equation that means that dt
of ud of t
belongs
to minus the subdifferential
of v at u of t
even the leaf
dt of ut
let me express it also the x variable is
equal to laplacian of u
d of x
and this is a very simple example
in the theory of of gradient flow but
this is an alpha gradient flow
so now we are ready for the very last
part of this mini course
where we i will introduce the
differential structure on the space of
probability measures
starting from uh the bermuda formula
that is a central
formula for us and then i will introduce
otto's
and this will allow
me to
to show how to interpret
data creation as gradient flow with
respect to the bus and to distance of a
certain function
and this can be also done for other
diffusion pds but we will not see it
today
and again all the computations are
really formal and you can see a more
rigorous version of this in the next
lectures and also in in the books by
ambrose
by ambrosio gideo savare
and in many other other places
so let me now start with the brilliant
formula
so
let me go away
so continuity equation
and
vermont
okay
so now we consider omega
in rd convex
um
also omega equal to rd is admissible
but keep in mind now
omega convex
[Music]
subset of rd
uh set
root zero bar
to be a probability measure
with
finite second moment
over omega
and
v
the vector field so
goes from zero t times omega in rd
b is a smooth
unbounded
on here it's bounded but it's not needed
it's a bounded vector field
tangent
to the boundary of omega
so if this is omega and this is the
boundary of omega
so this is omega at each point we can
draw the the the normal vector that is
nu
and then we have that
each time
the vector field is tangent
to
the boundary of omega
then what we can do is that we can
associate a flow to the vector field phi
so let
x
of t x
be the flow
associated
to b
that means
that we have
that x dot of t little x is equal to the
vector field phi at time t
at position capital x of t little x
and the starting point of capital x of
zero little x is little x
and then set
can you hear me
yes yeah can you clarify how you define
the vector field inside the outside the
boundary so here you just say it's taken
to
uh
the battery of omega but it's just
anything inside of it
um outside i'm not considering anything
so it's inside
inside
no i'm not saying anything that now is a
general vector field i'm not saying how
it is defined inside omega
so
i'm just saying that to each to any
smooth vector field
i can associate a
flow i i want it tangent because in
sense i want nothing to escape from
omega
okay also because these these measures
are with second
with the second moment bounded and we
want to keep also
this other measure that i'm defining now
roti in uh in the space of probability
with second moment bounded so we set now
row t
to be
the measure that is obtained from root
zero bar
if we do the push forward through x of t
so
the map x of t push forward zero bar and
we can say that this
again
still belongs to the space of
probability measures
with the second moment
over omega
and if we call bt
our vector field just
i i put uh the padding's t for because
it's here easier than
the continuity equation
that is
dt protein plus divergence
of vt rho t
equal to zero
this is ce
alts in the sense of distributions
uh this i'm sorry with also the
with also the constraint that bt scalar
product new
on the boundary equal to zero these
holds
in the sense
of distributions
so now we are ready for the definition
of action of this couple roti and bt
so definition
here the term action really reminds what
happened in uh in classical mechanics
and it's actually the same
and it's very natural also to see how
this will be linked to the vases time to
distance
so given
a pair
proti dt
solving
the continuity equation
with
mu equal to 0
on boundary of omega
then the action
of
rotivo t is the following functional
defined
as follows is the integral in zero
between zero and one
of the integral uh integral of omega
v t
of x
square root t of x
dx and
dt and uh
with this definition we are now
ready to to introduce the venomous
formula that relates the the action
um with the continuity equation and also
with the the bosses and two equation
and uh
as you may
remember the the action function in
classical mechanics are also used as a
minimizer let's say
along a long path
so
this is the same the very same spirit so
theorem
so uh given
now root zero bar and row one bar in the
space of probability measure over omega
with second finite moment it tolds that
the two buses and distance squared
between root zero bar and one bar
is the infimum
of what
of the action
with the constraint that root zero is
equal to 0 bar
rho 1 is equal to rho 1 bar
and that
rho t and vt satisfy the continuity
equation dt rot plus divergence of
omega
so
this is a specific link
with with the between the action and the
buses and to distance and
the quality happens if roti
so the quality
if
roti
is a business than to judassic
as we
presented it before
and vt
is
a vector field
such that the flow
associated to bt
is
satisfies
x t
x
equals t
t of x uh plus one minus t
x
and that is exactly what what we have
seen before
for for the for the geodesics in
investors time
now with this uh great formula we can we
can start um
the
reasoning to to arrive to autos
formulation so to otto's definition of
vastus tank scalar product end of
gradient flowing buses tend to so let me
start again from from from this
definition let me write it again
um
[Music]
more explicit so bus is 10 2 between
square between 0
0 bar row 1 bar
this is the infimum
over row t
b t
integral
between 0 and 1
of
integral over omega
v t
square protein
this is dx this is dt
such that we have the continuity
equation
so dt i will not write it all the time
so detail t plus divergence of vt
protein equal to zero
and then we have bt scalar product
with no
so vt
tangent to the boundary and root 0 equal
to 0 bar and row 1 equal row 1 bar
now we have two minimization one
minimization over
row t
and one minimization over
vt
and
one can prove
that
since
one of the constraint is let's say we
are minimizing also over bt so the
vector field and we are minimizing
upward of integral on omega
so probably is better if i copy paste
let me see
no probably i'm too bad with without
that
so of this
but um next time i will not copy paste
i'm sorry i did a mistake
um
so i pay my laziness
so such that divergence
of
vt
roti
is equal to minus dt
protein
and
vt
dot mu
equal to zero
and all this is in the t
now we can we have a nice expression
here
inside the time integral
it is this one
and we we can
select
this expression to be
the norm
to be the norm
of dt
rho t
at the point ro t square
so then um
after this
for the minimization integral t we need
to add that
root zero
that root zero is equal to zero bar and
row one is equal to the one for the
second minimization
so
now we we use that for each time t given
root t and dt of t one can minimize with
respect to all vector fields such that
the divergence of relativity is equal to
minus dt over t so before we can define
the vastus norm of the derivative of d
theta t at root t in this way as i as i
as i mentioned so in in pink so this is
the basta stein
nor
and once we have this vast style norm
so um
let's say we can then define also a
gradient from that so in other words
thanks to the continuity equation
um at each time t we have a constraint
of the divergence of bt routine
that allow us to rewrite the beramont
bernie formula in this way so we have w
two distance between root zero and row
one
bar
to be the inf
over t
of integral between zero one
of the vastest norm
of dt pro t
squared at the point root t in dt
such that root zero equal to zero bar
and for one equal to one bar
and this is
vera mobrine
so now
after some computations it turns out
that the optimal
[Music]
vector field v t is given by a gradient
of a function if you want and if we have
time i will show you the computation in
the end but i keep these computations
let's say only if we have time for now
so
let's just
let's just uh take for good that bt
is given
by a gradient of a function psi
psi t
and here again we see the special rule
of the gradient of functions for for
minimizing because vt is the is the
optimal so the optimal bt
it's given by the gradient of psi t so
we get that the vast strain norm of dt
protein
at root t square is equal to the
integral you know over omega of gradient
of psi t
square
root t
the x
where
psi solves
an ellipse
neumann
problem
these of course assuming that rho is
is nice and smooth
so psi solves slightly solves divergence
of roti
gradient of psi t
equal minus dt of roti
on omega with the constraint with the
neumann with the neumann condition that
um
we have zero no
condition
so on the boundary and this problem
uh
admits a unique solution uh
up to constants so exists unique
solution
up to constant
so
more generally now we can say that given
rho
a probability measure over omega
h a function from omega to r
such that the integral over omega of h
is equal to 0 and this condition is just
to ensure that the elliptic problem
has a solution
so h will be here this will be the h
that we see now and we want h to be
to have integral zero in this case of d
t rho t the condition was automatically
verified because this is the
derivative in time of um of row but the
integral
over omega of rho is equal to one so the
derivative is
zero
gives zero so it's fine
and we can define
the vast stein norm of h
at rho
square to be integral over omega of
graph psi square
rho dx
where psi solves divergence of
rho graph psi equal minus h
with neumann boundary condition
okay and
of course once the norm is defined we
can canonically construct a scalar
product
so definition
so given now
h1 and h2
from omega
to r
both with integral zero so integral over
omega of h1 equal integral over omega of
h2 equal to zero
so we can define the vast system scalar
product
of h1 and the two lh2 at row so define
the bar system
in the following way
so
we take h1
h2 scala product rule to be
an integral
over omega of graph
psi 1 square product rad psi 2
rho dx
where
uh
we have the the equation satisfied by
psi 1 m psi 2 that is divergence of rho
graph of psi i equal minus h i
on omega
and we have
as before
the psi i over the new equal to 0 on the
boundary
i equal 1 2.
so this is the definition of vasa stein
scalar product that i know that looks
really counterintuitive
i mean because of this uh of this
complicated uh formulation but i hope
that the flow of thoughts makes sense
um so let me now go on from that
because once we have
a scar product as before we are allowed
to define
the gradient of a functional universal
space because the goal is to define
gradient flows in the university space
so now
given
a functional capital f
from the space of probability over omega
or r
so its gradient
with respect
to
the system scalar product
at
robar
is the unique function
grada
w2
f of rho bar
of course if x if it is either it exists
such that we have that
grabbed
over
inverse system 2 of f
at root bar
against
variation
of a curved
epsilon evaluated at epsilon equal to
zero
this is at the point rho bar
is d over d epsilon
evaluated at epsilon equal to zero of
the functional of rho epsilon
for any smooth for any
smooth
curve
epsilon from minus epsilon zero epsilon
zero
to
two p of
omega
with
root zero equal rho bar
because everything now is centered in
neuropath
and so this is
the fundamental definition that we
needed
and now the next goal is to find an
explicit an explicit formula for the
vast ingredient of a function because
this is
not yet clear really what it means
so
if we denote
by
delta of
calligraphical of robar
delta of rho
the
l2 first variation
of f
this is simply the function in l2
so this
is the function
such that
d over d epsilon
evaluated at epsilon equal to zero of f
of r epsilon
is equal to the integral over omega
of this first variation the
f
of rho bar
with respect to
rho
against
the d repsilon the epsilon at epsilon
equal to zero
in the x
and recalling the differ the definition
of gradient
since
this is equal
to
this is equal to the grade to the
to the scalar product between the
gradient
of uh investors into f of robar
against this this first five dis
variations this is equal
to
graph
w2
f of rho bar
against this variation curve the rho
epsilon over sine in the epsilon
against f
at robar
and now
if we denote
by psi the solution
of the of the equation
divergence
of graph psi rho
bar
equals
minus
d r epsilon over the epsilon
evaluated at 10 equal to zero what we
can recognize so this week
again
with
zero
neumann
boundary condition
what we can recognize is that
now we'll try again to copy paste let's
see if i manage
we have that the gradient inverse system
two
of uh calligraphic f
is equal to minus integral over omega
of the l to gradient uh f2 first
variation of the functional
at rho bar
with respect to rho
divergence of graph c
rho bar in the x
and this is exactly
i'm sorry this is with a plus
this is with a plus and then minus
because we integrate by part and this is
integral
of the
divergence so of gradient of
this first variation
scalar product
graph c
against rho bar dx
and this will really ease the definition
of the vasa sense color product so we
can deduce
finally that
the gradient
invasion two of the calligraphic f of
rhobar is equal to minus divergence
of
of cloud of the first variation at robar
of our function
rhobar
and this is
the formula that that we needed
and just let me now conclude
with an example so now
if
f of r
is the integral
over omega of u
of rho of x dx so it has a simple form
with u
that goes from r to r
then for any smooth variation
epsilon into epsilon
it holds that d over d epsilon epsilon
equal to zero f of rho what it is is
simply d over the epsilon
of integral over omega of u of r epsilon
of x dx
and this is equal to integral over omega
of u prime
of rho
bar
of x
d
rho epsilon over d epsilon at epsilon
equal to zero in the x
and you see
now
that this is exactly
the the l2 first variation of the
functional that that we were discussing
above
and so we have that the l2
first variation of f at probably
is equal to u prime of rho bar of x
and therefore
the gradient
in both essential
of the functional
can be rewritten as
minus divergence of robar gradient
of u prime
of rho bar
that is minus divergence
rho bar
u second
at rho bar
and
an example now that that is very special
is the case where u of s
is s
log s
so f that is equal
to the integral
so f of rho
that is equal to the integral over omega
of
rho of x log
of x
this is the entropy function
then we
with this
this special in this special case then
you second less is one of the less
therefore the gradient
the vases and two gradient
of the
entropy functional
at the robot is equal to minus laplacian
over a bar
so to conclude
given f oops
i did a mistake
um given
f
from
pi 2 over omega of omega to r
then a curve
of probability measures
row from zero t
to
p2 over omega
is a dragging flow
of f
inverse system 2
starting
from
root 0 bar
if
dt of rho t
equal minus gradient
inverse's time of f
of routine
and root zero equal root zero bar
and this tell us
that the vastest time gradient flow
of the entropy
is data question
that is dt rho
equal minus grad
plus sin 2
of f or bro and that is equal to laplace
and this was um what i really wanted
to say to to to give a sense to this to
our class to have to see something
something important although all these
computations were really really formal
uh
now i don't know if we have time but
it's really not necessary if you want to
me to explain it i can show you why
um
if
if the vector field is a minimizer then
it is the gradient of a certain function
p but this is mostly up to you because
we already
late on the schedule due to my technical
problems so i i again apologize for for
the technical problem that we had in the
beginning i hope now it is it was okay
no
it's not really it's not really a matter
of two minutes so
um
it's fine we can skip it it's nice to
have a jolly that one can skip if he's
late
okay so thanks
[Music]
thank you it was very clear
so thanks again and have a nice
continuation bye